Und Tierversuche finde ich
auch echt belastend.
- Ich könnte jetzt z.B.
nicht den Hund meines Nachbarn
in einen Versuch einschleusen,
das könnte ich nicht.
- Man atmet die letzten Atemzüge mit.
Das erste Mal brauchte ich
danach erst mal einen Hug.
- Hi, ich bin Flo.
Ich bin Physiker und Biologe.
Und ich mache Tierversuche.
- Hi, Ich bin Livia. Ich studiere
Medizin und ich arbeite mit Mäusen.
- Ich heiße Mona Kiebert,
ich habe Pharmazie studiert
und habe im Rahmen meiner
Masterarbeit mit Mäusen gearbeitet.
Ich habe am Glioblastom geforscht.
Das sind die malignistischten
Hirntumore die es gibt,
also die bösartigsten.
- Im Rahmen meiner Doktorarbeit
untersuchen wir,
wie sich das Gehirn bei chronischen
Erkrankungen verändert.
- Man kennt das,
es gibt Leute der Hirnforschung,
die irgendwelche Krankheiten
untersuchen.
Alzheimer, Parkinson,
was auch immer.
Ich stelle die Frage
ein bisschen umgekehrt.
Nicht, wie geht
unser Gehirn kaputt?
Sondern, warum passiert das
eigentlich nicht ständig?
- Die Operation war eine
stereotaktische Operation.
Stereotaktisch heißt, die Maus
wird statisch festgehalten,
dann werden gewisse Koordinaten
genommen, um diese Krebszellen
genau in dieses Hirnarial
zu pflanzen,
damit es dort anwächst, um sie dann
mit Medikamenten zu behandeln,
und zu schauen,
ob der Krebs zurückgeht
oder wenigstens die Migration.
- An einem Tag, an dem ich
eine Untersuchung gemacht habe,
habe ich morgens erst mal die eine
Ratte, die ich untersuchen wollte,
aus der Tierhaltung abgeholt. Bin
mit dem Aufzug mit ihr hochgefahren,
hab dann einige Minuten mit ihr
gespielt, sie in den Arm genommen,
sie unter meine Achsel gehalten,
da fühlen sich Ratten wohl.
Schön dunkel, schön warm.
Danach habe ich sie
einschlafen lassen,
damit meine ich nicht einschläfern,
sondern, sie hat ein
Betäubungsmittel bekommen.
Und danach, weil ich ihr
ins Gehirn sehen wollte,
und sehen wollte, was passiert,
wenn sie bestimmte Töne hört,
und welcher Bereich des Gehirns
da was tut,
musste ich eine Öffnung
in ihren Schädel machen,
damit ich mit dem Mikroskop
hineinschauen kann.
D.h., ich habe ihren Kopf rasiert,
mit dem Rasierer, den ich auch
zu Hause habe, einem Barttrimmer.
Und dann kam
der ganz schwierige Moment.
Der Moment, in dem ich mit
der Chirurgie anfangen muss.
In dem Moment, in dem ich wusste,
jetzt geht es los,
jetzt mache ich einen Tierversuch.
- Während der OP schaltet man
rechts und links aus.
Man macht diese OP,
man will die Maus
nicht länger als nötig
in der Narkose haben,
sondern eher so kurz wie möglich.
Dann ist es protokollarisch.
Man macht diese OP
und rechts und links verschwindet.
- Man sieht nur noch vor sich,
aha, Fell, aha Knochen,
aha, mein Werkzeug usw.
Man denkt sehr technisch.
- Man sieht auch nicht die Maus
an sich, man sieht den Schädel,
man macht diesen Schädel auf,
man sieht den Schädelkopf,
man nimmt die Koordinaten. Es es
anstrengend, es ist sehr intensiv.
Man sieht aber nicht
die Maus an für sich,
sondern erst nach der OP,
wenn sie sich dann wieder putzen,
und wenn man denkt,
wow, ich habe dieser Maus
diese OP angetan und die leben
trotzdem weiter und putzen sich.
Ja. Und wenn man sie wirklich
so lebendig sieht,
dann tut es einem irgendwo leid.
- Wenn der Versuch rum ist,
kommt das alles wieder.
Man hat ja nicht vergessen, was
man tut und das es eine Ratte ist.
- Ich könnte jetzt z.B. nicht
den Hund meines Nachbarn
in einen Versuch einschleusen,
das ginge nicht,
das könnte ich nicht über mich
bringen, da ist zu viel Erinnerung,
zu viel Beziehung zu dem Tier. Ich
glaube, das darf man nicht haben,
wenn man Versuche macht,
dass man Tieren Namen gibt,
und die behandelt
wie ein eigenes Haustier.
Ich glaube,
das würde einem nicht gut tun.
- Ich hatte, als ich angefangen habe,
ein Buch geschenkt bekommen.
Tilda Apfelkern. Das war
ein Kinderbuch über eine Maus.
Das konnte ich nicht weiterlesen,
weil ich mit Mäusen gearbeitet habe.
- Warum konntest du
es nicht weiterlesen?
- Wenn ich mir vorstelle,
so eine kleine Tilda Apfelkern,
die eine Personifizierung dort hat,
das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen,
so einer kleinen Tilda
einen Tumor einzusetzen.
Wenn die Therapie fertig ist,
um einen Endpoint zu bekommen,
ob die Therapie angeschlagen hat,
oder nicht,
werden die Mäuse euthanisiert.
- Was bedeutet das?
- Getötet.
Eingeschläfert. Mit CO2.
Danach wird die Schädeldecke
aufgemacht, das Gehirn entnommen,
dann wird es eingefroren und es
werden kleine Schnitte genommen,
um unterm Mikroskop zu schauen,
ob der Tumor zurückgegangen ist.
Und ob die Therapie angeschlagen hat.
Ich habe täglich
mit den Tieren verbracht.
Man gewöhnt sich an die Tiere,
die gewöhnen sich auch an einen.
Und es tut einem natürlich super
leid, wenn man sie einschläfern muss.
Und das mit CO2. Man atmet die
letzten Atemzüge auch noch mit.
Und das erste Mal brauchte ich
natürlich erst mal einen Hug.
- Das Töten der Studien-Tiere,
gehört zu den Versuchen dazu.
Es ist geplant,
am Ende jedes Versuchs,
also bei mir nach ein paar Monaten,
d.h., das Töten von Tieren
ist ein Bestandteil
meiner Arbeit.
Schön ist das Töten von Tieren nicht.
Ich kenne niemanden,
der das leichten Herzens tut.
In meinem Fall liegt es daran,
v.a., dass wir die Gehirne
von den Mäusen brauchen,
um die weiter zu untersuchen,
um möglichst viel Wissen
von den Tieren zu gewinnen.
D.h., da komme ich nicht drum rum,
die Tiere auch am Ende zu töten.
- Wenn ich am Ende der Versuche
die Ratte töten musste,
war das für mich
immer eine sehr emotionale Sache.
Ich habe sie dann in die Hand
genommen, ihr eine Spritze gegeben,
mit einem Betäubungsmittel, mit einer
Überdosis eines Betäubungsmittels.
Und hab das getan, was beim
Tierarzt einschläfern heißt,
aber das bedeutet eben,
ich habe sie getötet.
- Es gibt auch noch andere Gründe,
warum man ein Tiere
während eines Versuchs,
oder während der Versuch
noch läuft töten muss.
Z.B., wenn man merkt,
dass das Tier leidet.
Wenn es aus irgendwelchen
Gründen Schmerzen hat.
Das sieht man den Mäusen an.
Es gibt Kriterien, wo man sagt,
der Maus geht es nicht gut.
Die zeigt Verhaltensauffälligkeiten,
oder sieht soundso aus.
Da sollte man den Versuch beenden
und die Maus töten.
- Nach manchen Versuchen
ist man sich nicht sicher,
geht der Maus, der Ratte
jetzt richtig gut?
Oder hat die möglicherweise
noch Schmerzen?
Wenn ich die am Leben lassen, hat sie
dann morgen Schmerzen, nächste Woche,
vielleicht monatelang,
jahrelang Schmerzen.
Wenn man sich nicht sicher ist,
dass es dem Tier gut geht,
dann muss das Tier unbedingt getötet
werden, da hat man keine Wahl.
Tierversuche finde ich ein
super schwieriges Thema.
Und Tierversuche
finde ich auch echt belastend.
Deswegen hab ich vor fast 10 Jahren
auch mal damit aufgehört,
Tierversuche zu machen.
Seit zwei Jahren mache ich
jetzt wieder Tierversuche.
Ich habe jahrelang nur
Computersimulationen gemacht,
nur theoretisch gearbeitet,
auch in der Hirnforschung,
genau dasselbe Forschungsthema,
aber andere Methoden.
Dann habe ich gemerkt, ich kann alles
simulieren und das Gegenteil davon
und es ist nur nützlich, wenn ich
es ab und zu damit vergleichen kann,
was wirklich im Gehirn passiert.
- Gäbe es eine adäquate Alternative
Vivo-Studien,
würde ich sie sofort machen.
- Wenn es ohne Tierversuche ginge,
würden wir auch keine machen.
Niemand macht Tierversuche gerne,
weil es Tiere sind
und wir gerne mit Tieren arbeiten,
sondern weil wir es müssen.
Gerade in den Neurowissenschaften
ist die Arbeit mit dem Tier
unentbehrlich.
So was Komplexes wie
das zentrale Nervensystem,
lässt sich leider
noch nicht modellieren.
- Deswegen hab ich mich entschieden,
dass ich wieder Tierversuche mache.
Ich habe mir dafür
Zebrafische rausgesucht.
Die heißen auch Zebraberblinge.
Die gibt es auch z.B. beim Hornbach,
in der Zootier-Abteilung.
Ich schaue mir die ganz kleinen
Fische an, d.h. Fischlarven.
Weil sie durchsichtig sind,
kann ich ihnen,
ohne sie aufzuschneiden und ohne OP
direkt ins Gehirn schauen.
Fischversuche fallen mir auch nicht
viel leichter, muss ich sagen.
Also Fische, das klingt erst mal so,
gut, ist ja "nur" ein Fisch.
Aber, wenn man den Fischen
dabei zusieht, wie sie schlüpfen,
wie sie aufwachsen,
wie sie größer werden,
das ist schon auch sehr emotional,
wenn ich sie irgendwann sterben sehe.
Wenn man einen Plan hat für
einen Tierversuch, von dem man sagt,
der könnte nützlich sein,
sollte man die in dem Tier machen,
das am wenigsten drunter leidet.
Und auch in möglichst wenigen Tieren
diese Versuche machen.
Für mich persönlich,
die Fragen die mich interessieren,
sind so grundlegend,
dass ich nur verstehen will,
wie funktioniert eigentlich
die Sprache der Nervenzellen?
Wie ist die Grammatik, mit der
sich die Zellen unterhalten?
Das kann ich genauso gut
im Fisch untersuchen,
wie in einer Ratte,
einem Affen, einem Menschen.
Und weil wir davon ausgehen,
dass Fische unter dieser Art
von Untersuchung weniger leiden,
als z.B. Ratten,
würde ich diesen Versuch
nicht an einer Ratte machen.
Ich finde, Rattenversuche
prinzipiell nach wie vor vernünftig.
Und ich finde sie auch
nach wie vor ethisch vertretbar.
Ich selbst will sie eigentlich
nicht mehr machen.
Das ist oft so, es gibt etwas,
das finde ich zwar an sich richtig,
aber mir persönlich
ist es unangenehm
und ich bin froh,
wenn es jemand anders übernimmt.
- Eine persönliche Grenze bei mir
bezüglich Tierversuchen wäre es,
wenn ich nicht selber überzeugt bin,
dass das was ich tue,
wirklich einem Zweck dient,
von dem ich überzeugt bin,
dass er ein guter Zweck ist.
Das ist das eine.
Auch die banalsten Tierversuche
würde ich nicht machen,
wenn ich denke,
das ist Unsinn.
Der Versuchsaufbau,
oder die Fragestellung.
Methodisch, was ich nicht tun würde
mit Tieren generell,
wären Versuche, bei denen die Tiere
ganz offensichtlich stark leiden.
Und das starke Leiden nicht
als Abbruchskriterium gilt.
Mich würde das schon belasten,
wenn ich merke,
der Maus geht es
echt nicht gut,
aber ich muss sie weiter
für den Versuch benutzen,
weil das dazu gehört.
Das wäre für mich so nicht machbar.
Da wäre für mich persönlich
die Grenze.
Ich hab auch im weiteren
Freundeskreis ein paar Freunde,
die sich sehr für den Tierschutz
engagieren, und sehr überzeugt sind,
dass Tierversuche
der Vergangenheit angehören sollten.
- "Der Tierfreund" ist
die erste Zeitschrift,
die ich je abonniert hatte.
Das hat sich auch nicht geändert.
Ich glaube, es ist kein Gegensatz,
dass man sagt, ich bin Tierfreund,
ich bin Tierschützer, und trotzdem
nicht prinzipiell gegen Tierversuche.
Es wäre mir sogar recht, wenn alle
Leute, die sagen, ich bin Tierfreund,
dass die sich mit Tierversuchen
auseinandersetzen.
Genau von den Leuten
würde ich mir wünschen,
dass sie Tierversuche machen,
wenn es schon jemand macht.
Weil ich mir bei denen sicher sein
kann, die kümmern sich um das Tier
und machen nur das, was nötig ist
und sind besonders sorgfältig.
- Ich habe auch einen Jagdschein.
Ich bin damit groß geworden.
Meine zwei Großeltern
hatten auch den Jagdschein.
Mit denen ist man in die Natur,
man hat die Tiere gesehen,
auch ziemlich nahe, man ist z.B.
zu einem Fuchsbau gegangen,
man hat den Fuchs gekannt. Man
kannte ihn, wenn er Junge bekam,
wenn die auf der Wiese rumtollen.
Und dann wurde man auch mal
zur Jagd mitgenommen.
Durch die Jagd,
ich esse Fleisch,
ich entziehe mich nicht
der Verantwortung,
ein Stück Wild zu erlegen.
Ich wäre nicht in der Lage,
ein Lamm zu töten,
deswegen esse ich
auch kein Lamm.
Ich kann mich noch erinnern, als ich
mein erstes Stück Fleisch hatte,
wusste ich erst mal,
wie viel Arbeit dahinter steckt,
um dieses Fleisch
überhaupt essen zu dürfen.
Der Schuss ist unter Verantwortung
eines jeden Jägers
und man will das Tier
so wenig wie möglich leiden sehen.
Und man will den Schuss so abgeben,
dass man so viel wie möglich
vom Tier verwerten kann.
Wenn man es falsch macht,
und es leiden muss,
was mir zum Glück
noch nicht passiert ist,
dann ist man traurig.
Leid an Tieren zu hören, zu sehen,
das macht traurig.
Aber ein Stück Tier zu erschießen,
wenn es einfach umkippt,
und nicht gemerkt hat, dass es jetzt
tot ist, dann bin ich nicht traurig.
- Aber bei den Mäusen
bist du schon traurig?
- Ja, also, wenn man
sie ersticken sieht,
das ist auch ein Tod, der nicht...
Man kann sie ja nicht erschießen.
Aber die letzten Atemzüge der Mäuse,
da sieht man doch selber,
wie soll ich sagen?
Es berührt einen.
- Ich bin keine Vegetarierin.
Leider, könnte man sagen.
Ich glaube, es hat sehr viele Gründe,
warum man Vegetarier/in sein sollte.
Ich esse es einfach aus Genuss
und weil mein Freund sehr gut
Gerichte macht mit Fleisch.
Ich fühle mich auch schlechter,
keine Vegetarierin zu sein,
als dafür,
dass ich Tierversuche mache.
In meiner Wahrnehmung ist
das Fleischessen verzichtbarer,
als das, was wir im Labor tun.
- Ich bin kein Veganer.
Aber ich esse fast
kein Fleisch mehr.
Ich denke da
sehr bewusst drüber nach.
Eben auch durch die Tierversuche.
Und ich glaube, es gibt fast
niemanden, der Tierversuche macht,
der nicht ständig darüber nachdenkt,
was bedeutet es, Tiere zu benutzen?
Als wären sie eine Sache. Sie sind
ja keine Sache. Das weiß ich ja.
Und trotzdem gibt es manchmal Fälle,
wo ich sage, ich bin bereit,
einem Tier Leid zuzufügen,
ganz sicher, in der Hoffnung,
dass dadurch einem anderen Tier,
wie z.B. einem Menschen,
irgendwann später
Leid erspart wird.
- Mein Labor war u.a.
in der Uniklinik Tübingen.
Ich bin täglich an den Patienten
vorbeigelaufen, die bestrahlt werden.
Und mir tat es eher leid, dass ich
diesen Patienten nicht helfen kann.
Also momentan nicht helfen kann.
Hatte dann aber auch jeden Tag
dieses Ziel vor Augen.
O. K., den Patienten
der nächsten Generation dann.
- Ich versuche den Leuten zu
erklären, warum ich das tue.
Und dass ich auch diese Gedanken
habe, dass ich mir auch überlege,
warum mache ich das?
Und bin ich überzeugt,
dass das was ich tue richtig ist
und am Ende jemandem hilft?
Den Menschen in dem Fall.
Das kann man nicht leugnen.
Wenn ich die Mäuse fragen würde,
ob sie da mitmachen wollen,
was ich mit ihnen tue...
Natürlich möchte keine Maus
eine Labormaus sein.
Das man an Tieren forscht,
um der Spezies Mensch zu helfen,
ist sehr Menschenzentriert,
sehr egozentrisch.
Da verstehe ich gut,
dass man das befremdlich findet.
- Es ist völlig o. K.,
für oder gegen Tierversuche zu sein.
Es gibt gute Gründe,
gegen Tierversuche zu sein.
Es gibt schlechte Gründe,
Genauso, wie es gute und schlechte
Gründe gibt, dafür zu sein.
Wir können darüber reden,
auch an der Uni, auch im Studium
und ich glaube, da
könnten wir noch einiges tun.
Ich habe einen ziemlich coolen Job.
Ich habe zwar nicht viel Geld,
es reicht für eine Einzimmerwohnung,
in einem Plattenbau mit einem
hübschen Blick auf die Stadt,
raus nach Tübingen.
Ich bin super zufrieden.
So richtig reich
wirst du nicht an der Uni,
Aber es ist ein genialer Job.
Weil ich was tun kann, von dem ich
das Gefühl habe, es ist sinnvoll.
Den Job habe ich, weil die
Gesellschaft sich als Ganze,
also alle Leute da draußen
sich gesagt haben,
wir zahlen super gerne Steuern,
damit der Kerl hier
Wissenschaftler sein kann.
Das Mindeste,
was ich zurückgeben kann,
ist nicht nur, dass ich
meine Arbeit ordentlich mache,
und dass ich alles
sauber dokumentiere,
dass es nachher auch
jemand verwenden kann,
sondern dass ich auch bereit bin,
den Leuten zu erklären,
was mache ich da eigentlich,
und warum mache ich das?
Und was genau sind die Regeln?
Und wer bin ich überhaupt,
der ich diesen Job übernommen habe?
Das finde ich super wichtig,
dass ich in der Verantwortung stehe,
gerade als jemand,
der für den Staat arbeitet,
an der Uniklinik Forschung macht.
Dass ich auch bereit bin,
rauszugehen und den Leuten zu sagen,
hey, hier bin ich.
Ihr könnt mir Fragen stellen.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2018)